Nikki hailey recently spoke to some high
school students I wonder if she said
it's easier than ever to make snarky
remarks or take joy in opponent's
mistakes or misfortunes it's easier than
ever to make snarky remarks or take joy
in opponent's mistakes or misfortunes
raise your hand if you've ever posted
anything online to quote unquote on the
lips I know it's fun and that it can
feel good but step but step back and
think about what you're accomplishing
when you do this
are you persuading anyone who are you
persuading now she's right
shutting down someone persuades no one
still does that matter
mocking Dana's dog just feels good how
can I stop but if you go online right
now you're gonna find - ugly sides to
everything yet if you decide to disarm
with the other side actually follow not
if they read the New York Times or an
op-ed today says if you want to be Trump
centrism is not the answer
urging Times readers to fear left is
like asking Trump to use bigger capital
letters fact is social media is getting
way worse on Twitter blue checks
celebrities just attacked one of their
own actor Mark Duplass for complimenting
just complimenting ben shapiro right now
the left seeks scalps by mobbing people
online for speech and ideas it's digital
warfare unleashed and so now you see the
right fighting back but there's a debate
among that side do you take the high
ground when you're attacked or do you
return fire it's mutually assured
destruction you smear me i smear you so
maybe let's stop smearing each other but
at some point we need to fire twitter
from our lives it's now a tool of
vengeance employed by mobs for cheap
thrills so Jack you're the CEO and your
company is now nothing more than an
online supermarket for people selling
torches and pitchforks
it's disgusting why not give it a rest
for a day shut it down look for a
solution as loud as Twitter can be
silenced can be
and more eloquent thoughtful Dana well I
just was very thoughtful I love Nikki
Haley's speech but but I just had this
visual of President Trump calling Jack
Dorsey into the Cabinet Room of the
White House and reaching across the desk
and saying you're fired but you know
what it's like markable there are
solutions to this I think I think it's
easy for nikki Haley to tell these kids
not to do it because she's not there
every day but there is a way to deal
with this I think that they should let
everybody have a chance to reset Twitter
just get rid of everything Kennedy and
that's some of the advice you're given
especially you know if you've got tweets
from 2008-2009 that you've completely
forgotten about like the guardians of
the galaxy yes director who wrote some
stupid stuff and even went on Twitter a
few years later saying hey sorry about
that stupid stuff I really shouldn't
that I was going through a phase
yes and then it was unearthed and and he
was fired and the question is how many
scalps will it take for either side to
be happy because they're both doing it
and it is pretty aggressive and there is
something to be said for relying on a
rational argument because we've gotten
to a point of such intense emotionalism
that people no longer remember how to
make an argument all they know how to do
is punch back and you have joggers
defecating in public oh yes I only did
that once Kennedy why bring it up on TV
what do you think Jason is this
unstoppable as that is the genie out of
the barn well in Europe they're actually
dealing with the right to be forgotten
you know I love that can you go to a
place and say you know what I get to
erase that part yeah and what I think we
as a society on a serious don't really
have to think about is how do we deal
with minors because you got 12 and 13
year olds signing user agreements to go
ahead and be out there and post all
these photos how is it that somebody
hasn't sued that living daylights out on
all these social media companies and one
for accepting a 12 year olds you know
use of Rights and posting up all those
photos and I think when you're making a
decision and you're underage
you can really have to live with that
the rest of your life is that kind of
affecting your job and everything else
there's
big question society has to answer by
the way I just I have a personal
experience here to share but I think
you're onto something where a young man
came to me for a job recommendation I
recommend him for a job he goes to the
person that I recommended him to then
the person calls me several days learned
says have you ever seen this guy's
Twitter da from media camp
it's the say I don't even know how and
we had this week one of the Milwaukee
Brewers pictures yes yes a kid 17 in
Maryland he's making all these horrible
racial comments well guess what somebody
digs it up now he's an all-star and boom
yeah it's a big problem
everybody's digging up stuff on
everybody else should we just declare
amnesty but this is then I think the
argument that you guys were making about
the political back-and-forth I mean you
smear I'm for both I'm I'm more with the
political stuff doesn't bother me as
much as the scalping like I want to try
to get I want to get wand fired by
finding something he said but the thing
is that bullying like that tip Nikki
Haley's point is not persuasive right
words you can say hey you know what I'm
smarter than one I had a better comeback
than mine but does it really persuade
anybody that oh yeah I'm gonna change
who I think you know Greg made such an
interesting argument I was thinking
about this and I'm thinking like that no
it just like makes people as nikki Haley
said dig in there I think that that is
embodied in the partisanship of the
country today or the polarization
because the numbers are actually what
you know how you were doing this yeah
they're remarkably steady I think that
everyone has basically gone to their
side yeah and there's only about 9% of
independent voters left so when you do
like this yeah can I come over or when
you smear - you want the Smuckers but
are they the ones in charge are there
are the independents the ones who decide
because the election really not
committed to either side because both
sides are so dug in I don't know okay
nope Republicans lose are they going to
be as upset as demo I remember when Ann
Coulter a few years ago maybe it was in
the 2012 presidential election she said
who cares about the independents to try
to turn your base out and and I you know
of course the RNC was like oh my gosh if
we do that we won't win they did it in
2012 but they did in 2016 but with two
very different candidates so I don't
know
I don't know either